maybe let's start the afternoon session
so our first talk is by cynthia vincent
and she's going to explain to us
uh many things about real logical german
all right thanks thanks very much to the
organizers for inviting me to speak i
will explain at least some things about
real enterprise geometry
um it's going to be a little bit of a of
a mix
um so real algebraic geometry is the
study of solution real
solutions to real equations um
sets defined by polynomials and
polynomials inequalities
and i want to do a sort of nice tour of
what can happen with these sets and why
they're interesting
so generally we're going to study and
this
probably will bore hopefully we'll bore
a large portion of the audience but
please ask questions if you have them so
study sets
nrn
defined polynomial equalities
and inequalities today i'm going to
focus on
equalities so just solutions of real
equations
because there's too much to talk about
in general so given some polynomials
one through fs say in n variables
i want to study their real variety
which is just the set of points
so you plug them in you get zero at each
so f1 of x equals zero
all the way through f of s equals zero
it's a real variety defined
vr of the apps to be this guy
to be their zero set or given an ideal
uh for example the one generated by the
s
for example things that look like the
sum of
something times
the sum things are polynomials
we'll define the real variety
of the ideal to be the vanishing locus
of all of the polynomials in the ideal
which is
for this example the same thing as this
guy so the x
an rn so that f of x equals zero
for all polynomials f and you're ideal
okay everybody with me so far
um so these are the sets uh you could
ask
and many people who study complex
equations uh would ask why on earth
would you want to do such a thing
um and i give many interests one is
uh it's interesting to do um so real
equations uh
i mean the real numbers have a different
structure than the complex numbers so
you get a lot of you can ask a lot of
different questions that might not even
make sense
over c so interesting
i'm just claiming that as fact and
hopefully we'll convince you
and second is
for many applications um for many things
in the real world
if you want to study you know solutions
you might want a real solution or even a
positive solution
um if you're what you're looking for is
you know the concentration of some
chemical or the placement of you know a
robot hand
you want a real knowing that the
solution is complex is not terribly
helpful to you
and one another reason that i
particularly like is you can draw
pictures
of at least in small dimensions of the
things you're talking about and your
pictures are sort of honest pictures
so we'll see some of that today um
of course the main drawback the main
caveat
as you all know is that r is not
algebraically closed
challenge sure challenge i like that
i'll put challenge man's challenge
um so there are real polynomials
without real roots
no real decisions
um so that's not too surprisingly where
all of the
tools that lots of algebraic genres like
to use start to um need more
um so what are some consequences of so
this you know
this means some things happen um so in
particular
something we've already something that's
already come up in um some of the talks
so far is that there's no
single generic behavior the word generic
needs to be used with extreme care
for example if i give you a generic
univariate
quadratic how many roots does it have
well zero or two all right
so a generic
quadratic say t squared plus a t
plus b
has zero over two
roots
um and the same thing happens when you
look at things that are you know
more interesting than univariate
quadratic so if i give you
um two generic plane curves
how many times do they intersect so two
say generic
cubics
so defined by polynomials of degree it
must three
uh intersect
and how many points well nine or
seven or five or three
or one
um if they're you know uh
so we can have at most nine real roots
maybe we draw two cubics
we're gonna go a bit slow at first so we
draw two cubics
we draw them let's say this is
the zero set of a cubic and
this is the zero side of a cubic
and they have nine intersection points
hopefully
so blue pubic green cubic
um you imagine as you move them around
some of those real roots might come
together
the intersection would be singular and
then move apart into two complex points
and we would lose two and since comple
you know since roots of
uh real polynomials have to come in
complex conjugate pairs we'd lose two so
it's always an even difference
um so and maybe if we wiggled them far
enough we would get cubics
with only one intersection point
and then these two cubics would have
eight complex conjugate
other intersection points
oh generic right yeah um
yeah you can also do kind of things with
multiple studios trying to be
trying to avoid that um
uh so that's um so we need to be a bit
careful
about the word generic instead you say
you know um
on an open for an open set uh for a full
dimensional set oh
open in the euclidean sense you need to
be a bit careful
so that's you know
that's one challenge um another thing
that happens
which is related is that if you do
things like project
um you might not get projector real
algebraic set you might not get a real
algebraic set
or even you know close to a real
underbreak set
um
um so
hopefully yeah probably you all have
this picture in your mind but if i take
the
for example a circle x squared plus y
squared
minus one and i project it onto
say the x-axis i'm not going to get
everything by a long shot i'll get
something defined by inequality
so the image is just uh
down
things between minus one and one so it's
not like
you're just missing a few points from a
real from an algebraic set you're
missing
you know whole intervals for example
um and more generally than that if i you
know take a
image of a polynomial map i don't get
um something with
something defined by polynomial
equations so more generally
images of polynomial maps
um might not be
real at breakfast
so for example
i'll define a map from r4 to
2x2 symmetric matrices which is
basically r3
and i'll send a vector
a1 a2 b1 b2
to the following two by two matrix
so a1 squared plus b1 squared
a1 a2 plus b1 b2
a2 squared and then it's symmetric so a1
and b2 so there's a nice algebraic map
polynomial map um what
is the image
inside so the image inside of two by two
matrices so the image
so some set of
two by two matrices
we were doing things over c if this were
over c
from c4 to c3 what would we get
everything yeah so well
it has to do with non-negative somehow
because that's true
yeah um so this is if we look carefully
the sum of
two uh rank one
uh the inner product of two rank one
vectors a one a two
uh plus uh b one b two times its
transpose and so we
make it is a positive semi-definite
matrix in particular
we get exactly the set of matrices where
the diagonals are positive or
non-negative so
n11 has to be non-negative m22 has to be
non-negative and the determinant has to
be
so psd matrix
so over c you'd get everything over if
you take this map
if you map the real points you just get
this full-dimensional semi-autobreak set
so what's the semi-algebraic set yeah
you get something defined by polynomial
inequalities
which you're not talking about which i'm
not talking about um
yeah okay
oh is that true general the image of a
bottom up in a semi algebraic
yes
um on this campus i think huh tarsky
side of her
yeah which i'm also not talking about um
yeah generally
yeah if you take a semi-algebraic set
and you do something polynomial to it
you get a semi-algebraic that
is roughly the statement of uh
okay um
so how do you deal with this once you
have you know once you know that
sometimes bad things happen you need to
be careful how do you be careful
um something that's come up in
in john's talk for example is that
discriminants
disconnect things
so this is not going to be a terribly
precise statement but if you have
a parameterized family at polynomial
cleveland
set of singular elements
often has co-dimension one
and removing it will disconnect your
space
and removing it
we'll connect your space so then you
know behavior might change
so often refers to both parts of the end
yeah okay this is a vague this is a sort
of
orphan and philosophy often has could
mention one and often removing it will
disconnect your smartphone
if it doesn't have convention long and
then removing it is not going to
disintegrate
right but is convention one sufficient
to
to having removing it disconnect your
space
is the question
oh everything is real yeah um so this is
this issue that um
that came up in john and john's talk if
you have a parametrized um
but we'll do an example let's just write
down the sample as possible
so simple as possible possibly i mean
are there real hyper services that don't
disconnect space
space a linear i mean productively if
you take rm
no you're in alpine space i think i
think hyper servers have to disconnect
it by um
by alexander you know it's somewhere
positive somewhere negative and you have
to cross zero yeah
i know one to the other so but but even
if you have yeah
yeah so yes yeah okay i think i was
gonna duality
no no no no no no you know
so for example uh our favorite our
quadratic is a parameterized system
i look in the parameter space of
quadratics and i look at the singular
ones
the singular ones form a curve in here
defined by a squared equals four
b
yes um and if i remove that curve i
split up my space of quadratics into two
pieces
and the behavior is different on both
pieces
so over here my quadratic would have
zero
roots if i used a and b in this region
and over here i'd have two real words
and what happens when i go between them
so if i imagine looking at polynomials
you know taking a path through here and
looking at polynomials here i have two
complex
roots when i'm up in this region and
then as i move towards this curve they
come closer and closer together
when i hit this curve they meet and i
have a singular point
and then when i pass this curve they
break away into two real points
um and
yeah i mean the thing that came up in
john's talk was that
if i could somehow avoid the singular
locus then the behavior wouldn't change
so over c you know you can
the complex numbers are big as a real
vector space they have you know twice as
many dimensions so you can sort of avoid
the singular locus and behavior doesn't
change and we can use a word like
generic
um and here that really doesn't happen
but the good news is that if we remove
these singular points then we have
regions on which the behavior is
the same where again behavior is a vague
statement but for example
number of real roots or a number of
connected components
slightly more adventurous
i have now two polynomials so cubic
y squared minus x squared minus one
times
minus two and a line
x uh minus a
now go over here
polynomial
and then i'm letting my second
polynomial move around a little bit so
i'm taking a line
and moving it around and i want to know
how many intersection points are
so you know for a over here we have zero
and as we move it
we might pick up some first we pick up
a singular point
turns into two real non-singular points
um and we do the same thing we try to
take a discriminant so this has
a singular intersection
for a equals minus one one or two that's
where this
line will be handed to this cubic
and then in between
these guys the number of railroads is
constable
um so if i wanted to know what the
generic intersection of this
would be i could take a discriminant i
could find out where the singular
intersection points are
i say
minus 1 1
2
and then pick any point in between you
know
take a equals minus 2 and look
and i would find for that particular
value that i had 0 real intersection
points and then i would know
this whole interview interval i had 0
intersection points for a in this whole
interval
same thing i pick some number in here
zero for example
um intersect the line
at zero and i have two real intersection
points
and then on this whole region i have i
know that i have two real intersections
like over here i have zero
and because i know i'm staying away from
this uh singular locus i know that
everything
stays the same the number of real groups
stays the same
and you can i'm not going to go into
this but you can imagine if i had a very
large
i had a higher hypersurface and lots of
dimensions and i wanted to do this
analysis i wanted to say project it and
find out how many real roots i had in
the image
i could take this and project it and
take a discriminant
and now i want to know how many roots
are on the discriminant i project it
again
i could take a discriminative
determinant of the screen then
and calculate exactly
it can be done um any questions so far
yeah yeah would you want to do like a
generic projection because it seems like
you chose a
very special sort of vertical line yeah
going across i did i chose a special
line
that's okay it still works uh yeah if i
took a different line we might get for
example three roots
rather than just two um this is just
easy to
other line will give you two huh no
other line will give you just two
for example any other lineman
um but you know it's this is easy to
write down and see and do by hand
uh this line always means there's a
point at infinity oh
if you projective you'd always be
meeting the same point in infinity
and then that's the only family of lines
that always means that one in energy
and so then you subtract that off and
you always get zero to two
but it still works even if you take you
know special assistants
um
so there's also true you can do not just
zero dimensional systems but higher
dimensional systems
and then you might be interested in the
real topology
uh so for example let's stick with plain
perps because we can draw them
removing singular polynomials
um
we're going to modernize and work
productively but
be the same so if i take homogeneous
polynomials of degree d and three
variables
um and i take away all of them that have
a singular point
um this disconnects this real vector
space
disconnects
and if i look on the connected
components that remain
there all of the plane curves in the
connected component are going to have
the same
real topology they're going to look
basically the same
is it an open question to know how many
connected components there are of the
discriminant
um wonderful wait
ask that again in like two minutes um
so playing cards
make my grounds take away the singular
ones
um
um
for example they have the same number of
connected components in
the same configuration so
probably there's even there's an ambient
there's a token between the two of them
okay it's even better okay so not not
just not just the set but also how it
sits inside a protective space
and that you can just take a path in the
center point
um you can
yeah that's a good way of thinking so if
you take you know if you move
so in the space of polynomials i've just
guaranteed you that you can take a path
from the polynomial you started with to
the one
in the same connected component um
and the roots are going to be continuous
as you go on that path
and so they're just going to deform one
curve
um
yes um
i mean in general so i'll do an example
but in general um i
it's known for example what's the
maximum number of connected components
you have
but it's not known how they can interact
with each other
for high degrees and
i would i mean higher meaning eight
yeah um and i think
probably based on that it's not known
once you remove this discriminant locus
how many
like chambers you get
i should also remark you may not want to
know i mean not once the numbers are
hundreds of thousands
it's very complicated okay um
but if you have a you know so it's very
complicated but i'm trying to convince
people that you know it's very
complicated but in special instances it
can be done
um so if you had a very particular
system that you were trying to look at
for example the acute
you know special type of cubic which is
fairly small
here's a cubic parametrized cubic
and if i wanted to calculate for example
which of these are bad so i can remove
them
i could enter something like the
following into macaulay 2.
so i want to eliminate variables
x y from the system of equations well i
want f to be 0 and then i want there to
be a singular point so
dfdx would have to vanish at a point
and that the fdy would have to manage
the point and if all of these guys
vanish at some point x
y then we call a and b bad then the
polynomial a b is that
so you also throw away the complex
that's true um but those are rare
because so if i if something has a
complex singular point
then i'll throw it away but it's its
conjugate will also be a singular point
and so i really have two singular points
and that's
less common so it's well mentioned
because you have i think what i'm saying
is yes
i think in one parameter families at
least
a parenthood's rational curves you'll
always run into
a pair of complex conjugations okay
lyrics even though you think it might be
good to mention too
it's because they're not independent but
even better
this can only have a singular
this is this is a cubic so it can only
have one singular point
so they're very all i was thinking about
but yeah you throw away complexities too
just in case
um
and what you get from this is a nice
polynomial
uh so if b is zero then it's singular
and uh
four a cubed minus 27b is zero that's
singular
those are the conditions under which
this cubic has a singular point
um
so if i look in underneath if i look at
this space
i take these guys and i throw them away
e equals zero
and there's a cubic section away
um i remove it and i get four connected
components
so i have four flavors of cubic that i
get
i can imagine let's see
if i take a and b up here
i'm going to sort of draw my curve
we'll see if this picture this is
disaster not but if i
drew for example the
real variety of the point
a equals with a equals four and b equals
one i get a real
cubic and it'll have an oval
something like this now i take my
parameters and i move them down and down
and down
eventually i hit this discriminant locus
and i get something singular so for
example the variety
of f40
what happened is that this oval and this
line will get closer and closer and
closer and i'll get
these guys get a node
and as i passed that
these two that came together split apart
in the opposite way
and i get so if i took one here and it
looked
and get a cubic with just one connective
component
and the same thing you know if i travel
this way and i hit a point here
what happens is that this oval shrinks
and shrinks and shrinks and if i look at
this
at a point right there i get the cubic
was just a point
on the line that's bad i removed it
and if i pass that point the oval has
disappeared
i know this picture is getting a little
bit crowded but hopefully that makes
sense if i pick
any parameters i get a cubic
curve in the plane and on each
connected component of the plane minus
this blue curve
i have the same topology if i'm
i have one connected component here i
have it on this entire region
if i have two here i have it on this
entire region
can you explain what's happening at the
origin of a b
and the origin is super singular
technical uh well we can look
so the origin is a cusp right because we
have uh y squared equals x
cubed so
do not try to pass through the origin
horrible
yeah so you might you know good thing
remove removed it
it's extremely singular
um i don't i know i don't know exactly
how the degenerations work but you can
imagine
the things just everything heads towards
the origin
um yeah
but it's sort of fun to look
um okay
and i'll just mention
so as frank said in general these
topologies can be
extremely complicated there's a lot of
options but a few things are known
um
is that if you have a plane curve with
degree d
um it has
at most b minus one choose two plus one
obtained there are curves that obtain
that so if you plug in d
equals three you get that uh
you can have at most two connected
components and here's you know a cubic
curve with two connected components
um if you plug in
d equals four you care about playing uh
coordinate curves
um you get that there's at most four
connected components
so here is you know
a coordinate curve
um i promise
uh and you know the sorts of questions
and i said about um general topologies
and not knowing how they interact so you
know another coordinate curve
might have two ovals and look something
like this
another coordinate curve might have two
note ovals but they might not
be inside of each other so three-quarter
curves
have different types there's even
a second one with four ovals that can't
be deformed to that one
so you take this figure and you smooth
it
there there's there there's
yeah there's there's there's an oval in
the middle and there are three out here
if you look at the tangents you can see
you can't deform it into this one
i think you remove the discriminant
locus and actually all of the different
types like this are connected
um yes okay
so that helped me gives you a flavor of
um
real roots and what happens when they
change um what i was hoping to do so
i'll take a short this is a super long
lecture so i'm going to do is take
a few minutes break and then come back
and talk about
a totally different aspect of real brake
geometry
and way of computing with them
namely certificates for telling for
example whenever the right is empty
and when things are
so um and some applications in
optimization
so let's take a documentary
is
so
in the second part of my talk i wanted
to discuss something
very different in style from the first
part
um
so uh everyone well maybe lots of people
are familiar with hilbert's mill solid
box but if you have a complex variety
you want to test if it's empty
um
this happens if and only you can write
one
as
an element of the ideal generated by the
polynomials
so i.e
um we would call this a certificate for
the complex variety being empty
because if you have a certificate like
this i claim that
it's the compass variety is obviously
empty why is that true
suppose you had a point in the complex
variety where that made all of these
polynomials zero
and you plug it into this equation then
each of these terms
you know is going to be 0 because it's
multiplied by f1 evaluated at the point
f2 evaluate the point et cetera so this
side is 0
and this side continues to be 1 because
one of values at points one
and you get a pretty strong
contradiction
so this means the concentration is
obviously empty
um
yes um
a real version of this real nonsense
um is the following i have a real
variety
so i take some polynomials i'm going to
have to have a common root and this real
variety is empty
and only if something happens if minus
one
can be written as a sum of squares
plus something in the ideal so where
changes are some polynomials
so what's the point about having the gjs
there
uh good so one it makes it true
so two but let's so let's actually see
so as with this
as with this guy one direction is
obvious and the other direction is
incredibly hard
um so and the same so i claim that this
is a certificate
for um the real variety being
empty and why is that true suppose i had
a real point
where all of these guys vanished and i
plugged it in
to this side of the equation if i plug
it into the sum of squares
i get a thing that's non-negative
because
you know if i evaluate each of the real
polynomials i get a real number i square
it it becomes
now negative i sum a bunch of
non-negative things together i get a
non-negative number so this will be
non-negative
if i had a real point and if the real
point
uh if all of these fundaments vanish at
the real point then
this element of the idea will be zero
um so if i had a real point i plug it
into this i got non-negative
plus zero that's non-negative um so this
is non-negative and this is minus one
which is again a pretty strong
contradiction so this is a certificate
for
um a real variety of angles
minus
emptiness of complex variety yeah
because yeah oh
that would not be necessarily what you
want because they're you know there are
things where complex variety
exists i that's true yeah you you need
something
more than this also also i i answered
that the conflicts on solid sides is
much easier to prove than the real one
yeah we do it in the first day and
alterate john through courses but that's
a lot harder okay this is
so i'll just restrict to the real stay
out of talking about complex operating
one direction is easy and i just did it
for you and the other direction is hard
and was done i think by art
in one
so what are these djs
that's a great question um so
yeah there's something that's not
negative
um so so the proof is there exists such
gj's yes
it's correct it's written but yeah for
some element of the ideal and for some
so there's no recipe for a there's no
simple recipe
no but the nice thing is that if you fix
so one of the reasons that this is good
is that if you fix the degrees of the
things you're looking for you can test
for such a thing
using a sunday definite program and
that's part of what i want to talk about
because this is sort of a company if you
fix the degrees much like here if you
fix the degrees you can
use linear algebra here if you fix the
degrees of the things you're looking for
you can use a semi-definite program
so the number of g's is fixed by default
fixing
uh if you fix the degree you can bounce
and you get a bound on the number
yeah here i'm just leaving it open
but even in complex case there is no
recipe to hook up his right if you
wanted to certify that the complex
variety is empty this is also
difficult and there are big bounds i
think double exponential times but there
is an algorithm there's an algorithm
so for small examples you know i can do
it um before my lecture
by hand so if i take two polynomials
and they have a circle and a line
circle
no real intersection points um
in fact i can write so i claim i can
write minus 1 as
2 plus y squared plus 1 minus
x squared plus y squared plus
x squared minus 4. let's check
that that's true y squared cancel with y
squared uh
x squared cancels x squared and i got 2
plus 1 minus 4 is minus 1.
that's true um so if we replace 2 by
c and move move that line
it'll stop working right so
i'm just curious what happens um
yes i think what happened so yes
good um so it's a good question what
happens let me finish so let's just
so this is just to be clear
a sum of squares
plus something in the ideal
and here we needed very small degrees of
things
to write this down uh things we
multiplied this by are very small
um i think as you get closer this
example is is pretty tame
so it might be okay but in general
the degrees might get worse as you move
around
you might need larger degrees of things
here to find
what because you're just moving that
that two to
this one might be okay you know so it
should be like
if it's x minus c it should be like six
square root of c squared plus
okay so then something should go off to
zero or infinity
add the homework so homework okay i'll
add one homework question so the
homework is what happens
um what happens to this certificate if
we put the content there instead
um but these are the sort of
certificates
that we're looking for um and
uh what i said is if we fix
the degree of
uh these sums of squares
one can test for these certificates
using a semi-different program i guess
to be pedantic you should also fix the
degrees of multipliers
that you're using for your ideal um
doesn't want to do the other
oh not necessarily because things in the
ideal might cancel homogeneous
or well yeah you can homogeneously okay
um if you fix the degrees of everything
that you're looking for
um then you can test for this using a
significant program
and i want to go into a little bit
of why that's true
and the main idea is that one can test
for sums of squares
using a semi-definite program
um because that's really where this
becomes a different
problem is that some of the squares um
so i claim the following
um a polynomial
and let's say that the degree is the
most
degree of 2d polynomial
um
this is a sum of squares
even only if something happens um
so if and only up
there is a positive semi-definite
q real symmetric
matrix all non-negative eigenvalues
for which f is equal to
a quadratic form in this
where md
is a vector binomials
this is the claim um
so this is a long so this guy
for example has is pretty long so this
has length
number of monomials and n variables
degree it must be
so length and
plus d minus one choose d
it's a long vector
um i actually want to prove this for you
because i think the proof is
illuminating uh or at least you know one
direction and then the other direction
is just reversing over the arrows
so suppose i have
such a positive semi-definite matrix
satisfying this
well then i can factor it
as a sum of actually size of the matrix
most size of the matrix uh
sums of rank one positive does that mean
definitely
vector dentist transpose and here the
number of these is bounded by
the size of the matrix for example
um and so what does that mean
for this so i've written f as
q multiplied on both sides by vectors of
binomials so that is equal to
so what happens if i plug this in i get
the sum over j
of md transpose vector
and this is a square
this is a vector transpose monomials of
degree
and most d is the sum of squares
and conversely if you had to sum the
squares you know you could take the
coefficients of all the monomials and
put them into a vector and
make those vectors into rank one
matrices and sum up all of those rank
one matrices to get the positive
significant matrix that satisfy
this equality um
and so why is that good is that so
that's the
check
um and what that means if you're set if
you're looking for a sum of squares
um you're looking for a positive
semi-definite matrix um satisfying some
affine constraints i claim that this is
an f these are
this equation um gives affine
constraints on the entries of q
because this is this is linear and q
this side
so you're asking for a positive seminar
matrix that satisfies some mathematician
constraints and that is exactly a
semi-definite program
if you don't notice any different
problem spine just think of something
that can be done
by a computer fairly quickly a
computationally practical thing
so testing whether or not a problem is
the sum of squares is a computationally
tractable thing
and by extension fixing the degrees and
looking for certificates like this is a
computationally attractable thing
for a fixed degree
any questions so far so what i'm going
to say about it
um
i'm going to be a little bit ambitious
in the last 10 minutes
try and tell you about an application of
this to combinatorial optimization
which is for people who were here this
last week we heard a lot about
commonwealth innovation last week
connections
polynomial
um
and really i want to do all of this by
way of an example
so we're going to do an example of a
problem in combinatorial optimization
and hopefully convince you that knowing
about sums of squares and real varieties
will help
you all this so an example is
independent sets of graphs
we have a graph it's got vertices
and edges
um a subset of the vertices
is independent if there are no edges
between any
of the elements of this
um and we want
the largest size of the largest
independence
so for example this subset of vertices
is independent
there's no edges between green vertices
but i can
make it larger what have i done
for example
here's an independent set of size 4 on
this graph
i think that's the largest i can do
i think 4 is the largest i can do
and finding so doing this for a general
graph is
hard in the computation in the
complexity sense of hard
but say you wanted to try and attack
this using sums of squares
um
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
cook up a real variety whose
consisting of finally many points and
each point corresponds to independent
set
and once i have them there maybe i want
to find the biggest one um
yeah is this equivalent to the click
problem
vice versa then it's just the same
problem as the click problem
so the complement of the independent set
is a click
yeah all edges yeah so largest
largest group in the complement
um so suppose so
let's get polynomials involved so i'm
going to work in a polynomial ring
where each vertex gets a variable
uh in this
to find an ideal depending on the graph
um generated by two types of polynomials
for each vertex i'm going to add
the polynomial xv times 1 minus xb
so if this is zero that means that x v
has to be either zero or one
if this polynomial vanishes and then
add the polynomial x v x w
whenever there's an edge
in particular if there's if x
b and x you're both taking on zero one
values
and there's an edge between them they
can't both be one
okay so that's my ideal and then
the real variety of this ideal
it lives inside zero one to the
size of the vertex
and this is the indicator vectors
our independent sense
and so in particular the size
of the largest independent set
equals the maximum
of the sum of the x i or v
over x in this real variety
okay so written as a polynomial
optimization problem but
polynomialization is really hard so we
haven't done much
but now let's uh let me
for example write this do a little
sleight of hand and write this as the
minimum
lambda such that lambda minus the sum
is non-negative on points
in the real variety of lines hopefully
that's if i've
not transposed something in my head
though it should be the same
and i can relate this what i'm going to
do is rather than saying
non-negative i'm going to say sum of
squares
and i'll get a bound so this should be
so i'm going to write
compare this to min lambda such that
lambda
minus the sum
is the sum of squares
vri which is not an equivalent thing to
do um but
should give us a bound in one direction
you need to bound the degree otherwise
it will
this is obvious one direction is obvious
and the other direction might be hard
for equality i
wish you learned is true
so this is a good point this is still
not even if this were equal which maybe
it's equal
it's still not that useful because the
degrees here could be doing horrible
things so it's still not computationally
casual
but um
a very nice thing is true um
so this was first approved by lovas and
then sort of expanded upon by
rob veya um pablo carrillo who's coming
here
thank you thomas um if you have a very
special type of graph if g
is a perfect graph not going to define
but very special
graph
then
this happens we get this inequality
um it's equivalent uh
to lambda minus sum of xb's
being a sum of squares
that's something in the ideal
age is in the ideal and the degree
of the gj's are actually one
and the conclusion of this
is that one can compute
stable sets of perfect graphs compute
the largest independence of itself
perfect graph
using a fairly small
number and some just using these sums of
squares techniques
um which as far as i know is not
something that can be done
from sort of straight up combinatorial
methods um
so that was a lot of stuff and i'm
slightly over time but let me
conclude that um so people are not
afraid of the real numbers i don't want
to do real to break geometry but it's a
really
rich field um there's spanning a lot of
things from topology
uh to optimization um and there's lots
of interesting open questions
on how for example other variants of
this perform
um
all right so plenty of time for
questions
uh
um so i think these guys worked on that
for a little bit but i don't remember
what the answer was um i think the
answer is the ones
so this is a very special case where you
can or you're really forced into
something very nice
and then once you once you have degree
two you know you have
a lot more freedom and somehow this
makes characterization very difficult
i mean maybe let me put this and as far
as i know i mean i also thought about
this for a while and they thought about
this for a bit that i think
as far as i know nothing came up i would
just do it the other way you pick some
other natural class of graphs
that's maybe a little less nice than
perfect
and then you see what you could try and
prove so there there was this thing
where
uh if you look at the so you have these
finitely many points and you look at say
the
poly token look at that or not even the
punches look finally many points
what's special about a perfect graph is
somehow i hope i get this right but
you can whenever there's a
facet whenever lots of them lie on a
plane
then all of the other ones lie on
one shift of that plane there's some
characterization like this of the set of
points
which here the set of independent sets
that is very nice
and they i think they did some work if
you have something like that property
but it's like two shifts of that plane
then you start getting degree twos there
but i don't remember
exactly the details about it and it
starts to get
a little bit complicated so i'm trying
to understand it too
so can it be maybe uh reformulate it so
that
you had before this real bush doesn't
sucks and that was the question of the
degrees and you didn't know
but in this situation of the perfect
graph it happens that
these g i have to a1 yes so maybe can it
be
is it equivalent to saying that you can
have in this context this
be a new stanzas representation you need
one yes
yeah so this is
uh certificate with very long degree
it's all about the degrees so
yeah so then i have another question so
i really wonder whether
in the real notions of what is known
about the degrees
are the
know so i don't know about the the upper
bounds has many full tower of
exponentials i don't know
i think the five full towers actually
what happens in hilbert 17th probably
which is
special case but there is a there is
well at least
by now there was a paper that was in
progress for a long time but now it
finally came out
and there is a there is even more
general you know this
was inequalities you can derive bounds
there are many full towers of
exponential maybe
have inequality foreign is that i mean
could it be that there is a single
exponential
upper bound lag in the complex notion
that's all that is obstruction
i mean related lower are lower bound
some kind of
conditions same order i i'm not actually
aware of
lower bounds for for whatever reason
people well people have not really
looked
all over bounds as much as they look for
upper bounds for example you can solve
those things
to have a single exponential upper bound
i mean for the real notions also or is
it impossible
that's my concern so for for this
combinatorial optimization
it's sort of very easy to show that
degree is always enough
and there are lower bounds which are
linear at least in
in m for combinatorial optimization you
cannot hope for stronger lower bounds so
if you always have this inequality that
x three times one minus six i'm thinking
of this general
so so i'm not i'm not an expert on
on this subject but if i recall the the
minimum value that a
positive that the polynomials can take
on on a set matter
and with real numbers you think things
can be you know things that
can go to zero remarkably fast given the
degree and that's what that's the only
thing that causes the
degree of the certificates to go go so
high i don't think that explains it so
well
it's much more soft there's some very
subtle things there's even examples
where for
depending on the sort of representation
if you're trying to look for
representations like this
something is positive on a set and
on a real variety and you want to write
this both on the squares modulo of the
ideal there's even cases where for
a fixed degree the degree of the
representation
goes off to infinity even just like
could it be
maybe for some refreshments whatever
this means
you don't have similar points and you
are far away from the single points
that you have better
seminar on september 16. oh wow
okay
get a bigger room
yes that's for more cost so there's more
complicated if you ask more complicated
questions you can get more complicated
certificates non-negative on a sunday
algebraic set
and she'll probably talk about the
certificates and how you developed
the degrees
more questions more answers
comments so to get this conclusion from
the theorem
do
the multipliers are going to be linear
they're just multipliers of the
of the defining equations uh not minus
or
they're they're just constants
i usually think of it as working
modularly ideal and then
is your original basis or how you
represented the ideal is that a growing
basis no yeah or i doubt it
um
but you can give this a little
okay so no more questions but thanks
you know this this might be yeah
okay